we've been talking over the last couple
of weeks about this new wave
of very radical and also extraordinarily
ignorant i mean completely vapid on
policy trumpian members of congress
the three we've been focusing on are
marjorie taylor greene
lauren beaubert and madison cawthorne
and the last
24 to 48 hours have been an absolute
disaster for marjorie taylor greene to
the point that now democrats are
considering
mechanisms to expel her from congress
and even republicans really should be
thinking about how do we distance from
this
absolutely outrageous radical two new
uh not new two videos have now come to
light um and in one of these videos
i'm sure many of you remember the
tragic and and uh completely
um uh disheartened i don't even know
what the word is to use for
the unconscionably tragic shooting at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida
and you may remember this activist david
hogg
who was a student at the time that the
school was a
victim to that mass shooting there is
video of marjorie taylor greene
um essentially harassing david hogg
following him on the street this was
first
reported back in june of last year it is
again going viral and i'm going to play
the video in its entirety for you this
is this is marjorie taylor green
a full-grown woman following david hogg
around washington dc harassing
him yeah
david why are you supporting the red
flag laws
if there had been if scott peterson the
resource officer at parkland had done
his job
then nicholas cruz wouldn't have killed
anybody in your high school or at least
protected them
why are you supporting red flag gun laws
that attack our second amendment right
and why are you using kids to get to as
a barrier
do you not know how to defend your
stance
look i'm an american citizen i'm a gun
owner i have a concealed carry permit i
carry a gun with
for protection for myself and you
are using your lobby and the money
behind
it and the kids to try to take away my
second amendment rights
you don't have anything to say for
yourself
you can't defend your stance how did you
get
over 30 appointments with senators how'd
you do that
how did you get major press coverage on
this issue
and how did you get kids why do you use
kids
why kids you know if school if school
zones
were protected by with security guards
with guns there would be no mass
shootings at schools
do you know that the best way to stop a
bad guy with a gun is with a good guy
with a gun
you're attacking our second and you have
nothing to say
no words don't walk it he's got nothing
to say
sad he has nothing to say because there
really isn't anything to say you guys
he has nothing to say because he's paid
to do this
he has the walk away march he's got the
um he's got the
women's march and they're funding all of
this every town gun usa they're funding
all this stuff okay
that was david hogue right there david
we saw him inside the senate building
he had 30 30 um appointments
where he went around and got to talk to
senators i got to talk to none
none he had media coverage all over the
place i had zero
guess what i'm a gun owner i'm an
american citizen
and i have nothing but this guy with his
george soros funding
and his major liberal funding has got
everything
i want you to think about that that's
where we are and he's a coward he can't
say one word because he can't defend his
state
uh and this is not the only video of
marjorie taylor green
harassing people that is now uh sort of
being revived
uh here is one of marjorie taylor greene
before she was elected this is february
of 2019.
she showed up at the house of
representatives
and was walking around the halls with a
bible
with the idea of finding congresswoman
ilhan omar and rashida talib
to get them to retake their oaths on a
bible rather than a quran
and you'll hear her talk incorrectly
about how the oath isn't valid if taken
on
a quran which which is just not true
here's that video
they signed that they swore in on the
korean oh
we have the bible we're going to talk
about swearing in on the how to swear in
on the bible
with them and let them know what our law
says
that you can't swear in on the koran so
we're gonna we're gonna explain to that
you know we're gonna explain about how
you can't swear in on the quran
and we're gonna have the bible and ask
them if they would swear in
on the bible that we really need yeah we
have the oath yep
so
[Music]
at the time they swear i don't know i
think at the time before
that wasn't passed yeah because it
wouldn't have been passing a republican
control
yeah so it was passed after they swore
in so they're not really
official i don't think so let's go ask
them to swear in in the bible
because like you said well holy bible
yeah it has to be the bible well the
bottom line is
bottom line is not compatible with
america yep
that's the bottom line that's the bottom
line
how can you say you represent women but
you support sharia law
this is currently an elected official
not just a low-level elected official
this
is one of 435 members of the u.s house
of representatives
and i don't care what happens to the
republican party
in terms of unity or
you know i i hope for the demise of the
republican party i think there would be
no better thing than donald trump
launching this third party he's
reportedly thinking of
and dividing the republican party if the
republican party has to fight off
trump's party
uh the patriot party or whatever it will
hopefully allow joe biden and democrats
and the more progressive elements of the
democratic party to get things done
that being said if republicans don't
denounce
marjorie taylor green's extremism if
they don't denounce the absurdity of
lauren beaubert if they don't denounce
the
just vapid politics of madison cawthorne
they're going to own it now maybe
they're okay with that
maybe republicans believe that they
should be going more in this direction
rather than going back to
not that it was what i agreed with but
more to the politics of people like
john mccain as an example or more in the
direction of someone like
mitt romney but the republican party now
has
it it's it's a contingent that i don't i
it's a conspiratorial
paranoid fringe radical element
that was not there before and there's
been a lot of radical stuff i mean
listen louie gohmert has been
matt gates these people these people are
bonkers but this is sort of just taking
it up to another level i'm not saying
anybody else is is good
i'm not saying i agree with louis gomert
i'm just saying this is another level of
crazy
and uh marjorie taylor green also uh
unfortunately for her uh some facebook
posts were uncovered where years ago she
was talking about
killing democrats and i think her
defense is that lots of people help her
manage her page
basically saying it wasn't me who
actually posted it this is absolutely
disgusting depraved
uh stuff and for the sake of the
republican party
um they should say that this does not
represent us
democrats looking into how could she be
expelled from the house of
representatives i don't know how likely
that is to happen
but extraordinarily extraordinarily
disturbing stuff
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
two hundred dollars off your order
and you'll get two super premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video